bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
mon sur rt france quel regard portez
vous sur ces événements ont centrafrique
c'est la première fois que la rébellion
armée attaque bangui je pense
qu'effectivement la situation d'hier est
préoccupante et grave le fait d'attaquer
directement la capitale bangui non pas
que les bandits choix sont importants
que ceux qui sont en province et
montrent que les rebelles sont
déterminées à faire tomber les
institutions de la république et en cela
je pense que et tous les partenaires
aujourd'hui dollar puissant qu'en fit
kane qui sont à ses cheveux doivent
encore redoubler de vigilance à ce que
les rebelles sont décidés à faire tomber
la république et et c'est quelque chose
que nous acteurs de la terre ne pourront
pas ses petits comment les rebelles ont
pu lancer une série d'attaqués aux
portes de bambi et les routes sont
surveillés par les forces
centrafricaines par les alliés mais vous
savez bien parce qu'elles ne sont pas
dans une guerre classique c'est comme
une guerre asymétrique est les rebelles
c'est qu'il sait des gens que vous voyez
dans la masse c'est des jeunes pour la
plupart et des fois qu'ils ne parlent
même pas 100 go donc ils ne sont pas du
pays et des jeunes qui sont prêts donc
ils peuvent se fondre facilement dans la
population et sont pas les déplacements
qui sont faites en cours et donc
certains sont arrivés depuis longtemps
d'ailleurs
et ils sont rejoints par deux éléments
donc ces conventions dans ça c'est
qu'effectivement c'est leur
détermination de faire tomber la pluie
centrafricaine est ce que nous disons un
rack analyse c'est que dans une relation
politique c'est normal d'avoir des
constatations c'est normal de vouloir
critiquer l'élection tout ça doit se
faire par les voies démocratiques
or aujourd'hui si la puissance graphique
henneton ce qui est important de voir
niveau de la géo pour cette région c'est
que beaucoup de pays sera impacté et ce
n'est pas pour rien que nous voyons que
beaucoup de pays de la sous région vient
à porter main forte aux forces armées
centrafricaines
parce que la démocratie ce n'est pas par
court dames c'est pas par coup de
pistolet il faut négocier il faut
discuter et nous pensons que la
situation actuelle exige donnera plus
car une chance il ya confirmé la
démocratie centraficaine faire en sorte
que la loi républicain pu s'appliquer et
que grâce aux forces centrafricaines
d'abord parce que je pense que tout ce
qu'on a vu hier c'est parce que la foi
centrafricaine ont pu résister c'est
parce que nous avons aujourd'hui une
fois
centrafricaine qui est en mesure de
pouvoir combattre mais aussi grâce aux
partenaires
vous parlez de la fédération de russie
et de la france de la ceeac du congo et
de le congo démocratique du congo pardon
et puis de l'angola qui va venir
peut-être la guinée équatoriale
l'instant des partenaires et d'autre de
la sous-région qui apporte un soutien
sont déterminants est il important de
noter que ce qui se passe entre
africains et ce n'est pas quelque chose
d'anodin
ces impayés qui peut pas continuer de
guerre en guerre qu'il ya des
concessions politiques c'est normal mais
tous les acteurs politiques
centrafricains aujourd'hui qu'ils soient
de l'opposition ou de la majorité qu'ils
aient fait des alliances ou pas doivent
aujourd'hui parce que c'est la
démocratie qui en juin soutenir l'effort
de démocratie et une fois que les
forains soutenir il ya toujours un temps
de discussion mais la discussion n'a pas
eu lieu sur le champ de guerre
l'addition n'a pas eu lieu quand on
prend des armes est là aujourd'hui c'est
que il faut que les ans ils remboursent
ensemble des missions de bons offices
pour parler aux commandités de ces
rebelles d'arrêter et que une fois on
reconnaître la république on aura en
tout cas ils ont un temps pour discuter
pour voir comment il peut avancer
concrètement mais sans faire en sorte
que les pour venir au pouvoir en plein
désert et ça c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut réussir à arrêter la pluie
centraficaine contexte sécuritaire
extrêmement tendue et ce que le mandat
de faustin archange touadéra vous semble
en sursis non je pense que c'est un
manque d'eau qui est difficile mais en
même temps parfois la démocratie sa
couche dans la douleur est ce qu'il faut
voir c'est que si il ne tient pas il n'a
pas la persévérance aujourd'hui d'aller
au bout il va arriver quoi ce que c'est
un vrai plaisir à voir une transition
aura un pays ne peut pas fonctionner pas
transition il ya fois tout n'est pas
parfait mais il faut que tu n'aies ce
qui est bon ce qui est bon c'est la
démocratie
ce qui est beau c'est en mesure de
contester un résultat le faire devant
les instances
la cour confirme et s'amplifie qu'elle a
déjà montré par le passé qu'elle est
autonome et prendre des décisions et
même sur what you see j'ai du rap
et parfois qu'elle est partie contre les
décisions du président et donc ceux qui
contestent aujourd'hui on le doit je
pense qu'il faut que cela s'applique au
niveau de la loi
mais je pense que ce fort mandat s'il a
cautionné elle confirme les résultats
bien évidemment pas ce que je peux en
parler avant n'a concerné et des mandats
de consultation de la paix qui sera sans
doute encore culture sur le plan
politique
parce qu'aujourd'hui a beaucoup
d'antagonisme des rancoeurs qui sont
aussi installés mais je pense que quand
il a décidé de consulats paix le pauvre
c'est toi deraa doit continuer dans cet
énoncé temps de la main et être dans ce
que nous appelons la capacité de faire
ce qu'il faut faire et non ce qu'il doit
faire et ce qu'il faut faire c'est de
bâtir la paire malgré tout ce qui allait
marquer les difficultés étudié tant de
la main et de continuer à tendre la main
tout en faisant en sorte que la justice
aurait pu sans toit fait qu'elle puisse
passer est ce que parce que c'est dans
cette situation sécuritaire il est aussi
question de la situation humanitaire
dans le pays
tout est lié vous savez quand il n'y a
pas la paix il ya tout est lié
l'association humanité en quoi des
déplacés aujourd'hui tout ça parce que
nous avons des gens qui ont loupé des
armes ou de contester par la parole elle
la voie des urnes
donc aujourd'hui quand on appelle au
secours au bas de la rue centraficaine
c'est plusieurs choses la première chose
c'est de réussir à donner la capacité de
défense aussi à ce pays
ça passe par la levée de l'embargo sur
les armes
faire que la fois à mes cinq enfants
sont autonomes en deux et soutenir les
acteurs que soutient la puissance
ricaine la musque à tous les partenaires
internationaux qui sont au chevet de la
france a fait tous soient présents et en
troisième lieu tous les formes par
rapport donc à la crise humanitaire
faire en sorte que différents
partenaires puissent être toujours
présent mais de tout ce que nous disons
il faut donner les moyens au pays de se
prendre en charge parce qu'en réalité
c'est la puissance graphique n a les
moyens elle n'aura pas besoin de tous et
dont on parle aujourd'hui elle peut se
développer tout seul
merci pour votre regard kag sanoussi
président de l'institut international de
gestion des conflits